[Music]
so there's this guy who gives away money
and does stupid [ __ ] on YouTube that's
all he does every day so now that we've
proven we have a hundred million Orbeez
we're gonna fill this pool in this
entire backyard with the hook he's kind
of innocuous at first glance generic
clothing gray Nike hat like any other
guy from North Carolina that is unless
you frequent YouTube where he's anything
but ordinary and has cultivated a
following that spans more than 17
million subscribers of course we're
talking about mr. beast
I spent $30,000 on lottery tickets
scratch off tickets whatever you want to
call them these tickets are $30 apiece
and I bought a thousand of them the top
prize for these tickets is 10 million
dollars so I could win 10 million
dollars or a couple million dollars or a
couple hundred thousand dollars or I
could lose tens of thousands of dollars
who knows a man who has made himself
rich famous and loved online for
capitalizing on the Internet's
unquenchable thirst for the insane the
unlikely and sometimes the pathetic what
I'm gonna be doing is I'm gonna be
painting this board and I'm gonna watch
it dry so I'm gonna paint this entire
board dry everyone ready he's the
personification of the Internet up for
anything as long as it's being filmed
and can include that elusive cliff Bait
headline
[Music]
jinnie mr. beast Donaldson joins YouTube
in February 2012 his origin story began
where many YouTube stories do with
Minecraft historically the most beloved
game on the platform alright it just
happened he eventually transitioned his
gaming content towards call of duty
where he spent years producing
commentary videos about the game and its
community what is going on guys I just
hit 300 subscribers which is pretty
freakin awesome I'm pretty happy about
it that's 300 people that subscribe to
my channel and real quick about the
gameplay this is a 203 kill game I got
on Nuketown demolition but as mr. beast
grew his brand quickly transitioned away
from video games
he made content about YouTube it's
celebrities and the money farm that it
was becoming this is gonna be a short
video but I'm gonna talk about how much
Gangnam style Gangnam style I have no
idea which way you say it has made off
of youtube you know he upload the video
to YouTube it got a billion views and
then recently hit 2 billion views and
right now when I upload this it has 2
billion 150 million views it was during
this era where beast became a YouTube
good guy his product was still
relatively small but he took a very
self-aware tact to making contact well
about contact how's it going guys today
I'm gonna be talking about how much
money dramaalert makes off of youtube
now if you're one of my regular
subscribers I'm gonna start
incorporating these type of videos into
my normal uploads because one well lots
of people search for how much youtubers
make and two I just really enjoyed
talking about youtubers and money
whatever and whoever was most popular
that's when mr. beast went from gaming
to general interest and you'd think that
would carry some negativity with it but
beast kind of owned it he developed this
clarity of intent even when his channel
was still small he'd do what it took to
grow but he'd never lose that everyman
honesty which was maybe best exemplified
by the first video of his that blew up
in 2017 I'm about to count 200,000
you don't believe me just watch this
video all I want to say is just tweet
the video I'll share it with you know
maybe key more scarce and if you're
youtuber just help a guy out
I mean think of the pain I'm about to go
screw it
well I was going for like our tea break
we went to call you a flea for two weeks
yeah and then I stopped going and I
didn't tell my mom for a little bit and
then that would I counted a hundred
thousand because I was like is when I
stopped going I just like I had no
future so you do it's that honesty that
vaulted him up the YouTube charts to
become one of the largest content
creators on the platform and he always
kept his small ties to gaming present in
his content even when he moved away from
gameplay footage and that's paid off in
a big way because now that he's a
YouTube juggernaut
he's capitalized on yet another
lucrative trend twitch stream and what
better way to attract attention than by
giving away hundreds of thousands of
dollars oh my god fifty thousand more
dollars to as far back as July of 2015
mr. beast recognized that there was an
appetite for watching people receive
boatloads of money oh oh look that I
love you thanks Frank that's all oh
thanks but that
come on you know we all dream of Sunday
just being handed a wad of bills and it
turns out living vicariously through
others paydays is good enough for those
browsing YouTube during their lunch hour
more recently beast has taken this
simple concept one step further by
soliciting sponsors to give him money
and then depositing that cash into the
bank accounts of unprepared twitch
streamers everything I give away in this
video was provided by quit there's
amazing like what other app does good
like this
[Music]
there's just no downside
beast gets his 10 million view viral
video the streamers get paid for their
hard work and millions get to watch
people lose their minds on the Internet
welcome everybody for mr veestrate oh my
god did you actually just donate it's
the circle of Internet life the success
of these donation videos is really
unprecedented and they've prompted
Beiste to make giving away money a core
pillar of his content over the last year
I don't have any cash but I got some
gift cards to get food and clothes and
all kinds of stuff yes sorry yes sir
that's the meat you rested he drops 30k
on ninja and jumped headfirst into
fortnight's meteoric rise on YouTube
he saw guys we broke ninja I think we
broke OH
you're not my oh my god lost my voice
man he never stopped donating to
relatively unknown creators and he
returned to ninja with 50k in hand
during his saint juice charity stream I
told you it's gonna donate 40 thousand
but I ended up donating $50,000 me today
like he said was it was just so
passive-aggressive it's like directed
right towards me he's the only way that
can be overturned is with a donation
larger than $10,000 but I don't think
mr. Bies even had that much amount
donate he donated ten thousand and then
he's like no way you can override this
is by donating over ten thousand and I'm
like what am I not supposed to it was a
direct shot at know all this in mind
nothing illustrates this wild viral
world more than his growing relationship
with fortnight's twitch super streamer t
food t foo comes from what can only be
described as a youtube household and
grew up making videos with his brother
juice wad this one actually took an
entire month to complete so if you'd
like to like this video maybe subscribe
and comment down below what you want to
see us build the inside diet that some
of you guys we're gonna give you tour
the inside really quick but next thing
we're gonna do is spend 24 hours we're
gonna spend the next two or three days
decking out the wholly inside of
SpongeBob's house we planned on doing
that before this video okay now but here
we are a month later so as Teva was
becoming one of the best fortnight
players on the planet mr. beast called
up juice squad to make sure he could
unload some cash on the young celebrity
but this time instead of simply donating
online he drove from North Carolina to
Florida to hand him the cash in person
now my paypal broke and I want to donate
you so I know the logical thing to do is
just come here whatever game you play
next every kill you get I'm gonna give
you five hundred dollars alright yeah
yeah it's just your piece
yo mr. beast is on my
and he's trying to donate to me I are oh
and then a couple of months later he
took it one step further we bought a bus
and now we're turning it into a battle
bus and then we're gonna Surprise Tipu
with the battle bus and to prove I'm not
lying this is T Fu's brother right here
it's gonna be hype I can't wait to give
it to him mr. beast built a real life
battle bus and drove it to T Fu's house
to donate it to the streamer and maybe
what's most interesting about this
insane donation is that everyone won
between all three parties they received
35 million views with mr. beast accruing
31 million alone it almost feels like
after all these years mr. beast has
cracked some sort of life code he gets
to do nice things for other people have
fun and do crazy stuff and people will
pay him to do it we're gonna go to bed
fine whatever you can carry I'll pay for
it but if you drop one item you get
nothing this guy is like three grand
seven grand
recently he paid shroud an unannounced
visit to continue his series and with
the help of Apex legends donated more
than a hundred thousand dollars to
charity basically apex legends hit us up
and wanted us to do a video with shroud
where we just donate money to charity
so we're gonna play like a few games and
every time he gets the kill we're gonna
donate a few thousand dollars to charity
to put a little pressure on you and by
we I mean a Pink Floyd more jumping
right in right now ya know this right
here what we're seeing here is mr. beast
showing us all just what the gaming
world is capable of the kind of reach
that's been made possible by the feint
which can create and just how badly
people want to watch an ordinary guy do
nice things for other people even if
they are a little insane now it's
obviously not that simple and there's a
lot that goes into making this kind of
production possible but we'll see cuz
this year's taxes are coming up and
that's when it's gonna I mean like
millions of the fine yeah I'm gonna be
bad you got it yeah exactly I mean we
have it all document we have receipts
and stuff but it's like the hard part is
like when I give my boys 100 grand
spend like I just thought that up to
that video of who pays taxes on it right
but over the course of the past few
months mr. beast has entrenched himself
in the twitch ecosystem and our waited
for the first game how does the great
chefs of the shoutout apex legends for
allowing it happen just give me your
paper I'll give you honey girl and he's
done it by being the good guy and so I
wanted to give you money to pick your
house or something yeah so I wanted to
give you a check of you pay for it
no yeah yes we need it though no a lot
of the time everyone feels faceless
online the gears are turning inside this
massive Internet machine and all of its
leaking out is in the toxic the gruesome
and the meats but mr. beast has stood
apart from that realm of the internet
for as long as he's been online and this
junk back into the gaming zeitgeist is
no different
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]